let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] him
[Music]
hump day
happy
happy
hump day it's wednesday
noon eastern 11 central you know what
time that is it is time for the tony
michaels podcast here on youtube twitter
and twitch
live coming to you broadcasting live
from an undisclosed location
in my liberal bunker there's liberal
hysteria this morning apparently
we are broadcasting to you live every
single weekday monday through friday
noon eastern 11 central from youtube
twitter twitch and now the midas touch
facebook page welcome to all of you out
there on the books of face good morning
good morning and happy hump day
apparently the right wing thinks
liberals are in hysterical they're
hysterical over elon musk
not buying twitter and losing
he lost
126
billion dollars of tesla's valuation
yesterday oh people keep tweeting at me
hey tony oh you're wrong about the elon
musk thing you know what if he buys
twitter at this point and he tanks tesla
[ __ ] him
i got
elon musk is such a super genius oh it's
such a great idea for elon musk to own
twitter he's a brainiac the guy is so
[ __ ] smart he's the smartest person
in the entire world he must be because
he's super rich
and he loses 126 billion dollars
yesterday
if his money is any any any indication
of his brilliance he's a [ __ ] dumbass
what a [ __ ] bonehead and then it
turns out and we're gonna find out from
our co-host gabe sanchez i got a lot of
questions he did a lot of research last
night on elon musk and his money but
apparently
it looks like if he backs out of the
deal he's got a paid twitter a billion
bucks that's right with a b a billion
dollars he's got to pay twitter
[Laughter]
tesla investors are pissed
oh twitter's happy is a lark here
twitter is [ __ ] just
swimming in it they're like yeah baby i
mean we get bought out for 45 billion in
over evaluation the stock the
shareholders are excited
the board's excited and you know what if
elon musk walks away because he looks
like a [ __ ] dumbass in cell rube we
get a billion bucks baby
what a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and and and it really is
[ __ ] brilliant that yesterday the
entire internet the entire right wing
was like oh elon is our savior he's so
smart what a super genius he is
and he tanked
he tanked the company stock that he's
gonna use to buy twitter
i would imagine i would imagine that
actual smart people actual people out
there who know what the [ __ ] they're
doing
saw this coming at twitter
i would imagine that's probably the case
oh [ __ ] you can't you can't
can't make this [ __ ] up i told you
yesterday the picture of elon musk
not even
[ __ ] sitting long enough for a
haircut and flaking on his barber was
enough evidence for me to know that that
this twitter deal is all a bunch of [ __ ]
it's all a bunch of elon musk [ __ ]
i'm gonna do this and he never does it
[ __ ]
it's what it is
that's what it is and i'm sticking to my
story and you can tweet at me and tell
me i need to listen to this person or
that person hell i'll have them on the
show
i'll have them on the show they can come
and prove me wrong i don't give a [ __ ]
i had someone in facebook yesterday well
you can't call me dumb or stupid because
i hate elon musk and i'm leaving twitter
good go leave twitter leave twitter
you'll be back in a couple months when
he flicks on the deal and you realize
that elon musk isn't going to own
twitter
he doesn't
own twitter
he does not own twitter
today
and i don't think he's going to
that's the way i'm going to stick with
my story i don't give a [ __ ]
i'm going to tell you right now my
prediction is elon musk does not
own twitter and will not own the
majority share or he will not turn it
into a private company
that is my prediction
and i feel like i am taking a pretty
[ __ ] solid risk by saying that
knowing elon musk and how elon musk
acts on his promises and what he says
how the [ __ ] can you take this [ __ ]
seriously how could anyone take this
[ __ ] seriously
twitter or anyone else
it really is ridiculous
it really is
ridiculous welcome welcome to all you i
know i guys in here i got oh man
uh was i i know i guy's in here and boy
he's really he wants me to talk to glenn
glenn kirschner oh yeah i guy was
tweeting it yeah i i know i hear a eye
guy i hear a eye guy i hear you i hear
you but i also
i also think that elon musk is full of
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and he's not as smart as everyone thinks
he is he's not the diabolical genius
uh he says i don't see the long game
okay yeah well i i i think that there is
no long game for elon musk there isn't
one
that's that's the problem and if i'm
wrong
here here yeah i guy says what if you're
wrong you are taking a risk why why am i
taking risk if i'm wrong what's the
difference if if the truth is that elon
musk will own twitter
in the long run what risk am i taking
saying that he's a flake which he is
i i mean really honestly what's the
[ __ ] risk that i'm taking if i'm
predicting that that [ __ ] which he is
an [ __ ] won't own twitter which i
don't think he will i i'm not just
saying this to [ __ ] say it i actually
truly believe
i am very skeptical
very skeptical of the prospect that elon
musk will follow through with this deal
100 percent skeptical that elon musk him
elon musk because he's the one
perpetuating this the [ __ ]
shareholders at tesla aren't excited
about this we found out yesterday
they're like [ __ ] you buddy
126 billion dollars the guy lost
yesterday poof magically into the air
now it's all [ __ ] because elon musk
being worth the money that he's worth is
all [ __ ] too that's why we need to
tax the ever loving [ __ ] out of him tax
him into oblivion put him in his place
him bezos gates warren buffett all the
billionaires tax them into oblivion [ __ ]
them
it's enough of this [ __ ] enough of this
[ __ ] were
a a nut sack
like [ __ ] elon musk with his stupid
[ __ ] haircut can run around running
rough shot all over our economy
and cause a [ __ ] car company
to lose 126 billion dollars because he's
an [ __ ] and he thinks he's going to
bring back freedom of speech which by
the way he's not he [ __ ] blocks
people what the [ __ ]
so you're telling me the the king of
freedom of speech the guy that's
supposed to deliver us freedom of speech
again blocks people on his social media
and that's freedom get the [ __ ] out of
here with that [ __ ]
he is a flake ass [ __ ] and that's it
bottom line
period you can count on nothing elon
musk says not a god damn thing not one
[ __ ] thing can you count on elon musk
not one and i don't think this is any
different than anything else he says
not not [ __ ] in the slightest
so we'll see we'll see what happens
but the other thing that people are
discounting is the steps that have to be
taken for elon musk to even buy this
to buy twitter
like
he doesn't just walk into twitter
headquarters with double bags full of
cash
and they just hand him the keys that's
not that's not even close to how it
works not even [ __ ] close
not even [ __ ] close to how it works
and the idea that there's some
conspiracy theories out there that you
know this is some grand scheme and some
[ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of here that
ain't let me tell you something about
twitter in a public company if there is
some kind of grand conspiracy and
they're [ __ ] committing illegal acts
to somehow thort
some [ __ ]
twitter's in big [ __ ] trouble they're
bored their ceo and anyone else who's
involved
they're big investors they're in big
trouble if there's some kind of [ __ ]
grand scheme to commit federal crimes
and some conspiracy it's not a
conspiracy elon musk does not want the
picture of him and justly maxwell
circulated around twitter and making him
look like a pedophile
or supporting pedophiles and groomers
and he hates that [ __ ] he hates the the
picture of him when he was bald before
he got his hair plugged he hates that
[ __ ] and he's willing to go on some
stupid ass lying tirade to act like he's
gonna buy twitter because he's a whiny
little [ __ ] [ __ ] that's what he is
he's a weak ass snowflake
and he lost 20 126 billion dollars
yesterday by the way
and
also fact
he still still doesn't own twitter
oh [ __ ] elon you you certainly are
delivering up plenty of content here at
the tony michael's podcast
uh and getting the chat going really
hard because everyone's in the chat
today i want to welcome everybody debbie
from salt lake is here robin's here
boris from facebook's here nancy uh
kathy's here
minus margie's here lisa from facebook
is here jay is here david is here kit
kat is here amanda's here crystal from
facebook bob from facebook holy moly we
got so many new listeners over on
facebook you know you guys should do if
you're on facebook you should go over to
youtube right now and you should
subscribe to our youtube channel so you
don't miss anything just go to the tony
michaels podcast just typing in on
youtube or if you're real fancy we put
the link right there on the facebook
post you can just click that sumbitch
you can go over and subscribe to our
podcast on youtube you don't want to
miss a thing you do not want to miss a
thing because you can watch it over on
facebook on minus touch facebook page
but we post clips we post shorts we post
all kinds of stuff over on the youtube
channel so make sure to subscribe to our
youtube channel and again we broadcast
live every single weekday monday through
friday noon eastern 11 central 9 pacific
on youtube twitter and twitch our
channels and now we broadcast live from
the midas touch facebook page because we
are a proud partner of midas touch
the nice part is if you're on facebook
you can go ahead and like the like share
you know do whatever the you do on the
books of face with your post put it in
groups share it with your trump
relatives i know you folks have
relatives out there that are trump
supporters send them this broadcast
it'll piss them off oh just send them
every single one of them it'll really
piss them off that's fantastic that's
what we're here to do really dig into
the trump humpers yeah really get at
them get at them get our messaging right
out there right to them because we take
it to the fight but if you come over to
youtube you can participate in the super
chat
uh and if you're not aware what the
super chat is everyone in the in the
youtube chat will teach you and we'll
show you what super stickers are what
super chat is
come chat with us over on youtube we
have a lot of fun or you can chat on
facebook a lot of you guys chat on
facebook and i'll try to pull your
comments in as we go now we are getting
more and more comments
as we grow the podcast here and more and
more people are listening and watching
so i i want you to
if you want to try to get my attention
put a star in front of it
and and i'll try to pay attention but
there's a lot of comments coming in at a
time and a lot of times you guys are
talking to each other not talking to me
but we like to bring your guys you you
the listeners we'd like to bring you
guys into the podcast as much as we
possibly can
as much as we possibly can so you people
out there who download the podcast on
apple spotify google because it's
available on all the directories
you know the people who want to listen
to my beautiful voice not exactly see my
beautiful face
but they want to hear
what we have to say here you should
check out every once in a while try to
make time to come over to the live chat
it is it is fantastic and watch
and watch us do the show as opposed to
listen but also you folks that are
listening you should go over and you
should download the podcast as well that
helps us out here at the tony michaels
podcast we appreciate all of you guys
we appreciate all your guys's support
and you guys showing up every day
robin says she sent me an opinion see
how robin's got her her comment here
she's got the alarms she's like tony pay
attention to me so you can do that or
you can put stars
in front of it like debbie has here
biden delivered
um
so we we've got we've got a lot of
comments here and they come in fast
so forgive me if i don't get to yours
just come every day
and try try try to get your comment and
again put a star in front of it if
you're talking to me if you want me to
to try to see it put a star an alarm
this is something hey tony hey hey
look at my comment
we love having you guys here thank you
very much for joining us
thank you
for joining us today today's hump day
we're going to go through the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends you guys
know my co-host and executive producer
gabe sanchez is gonna join us at the
bottom of the hour as he usually does i
think he's gonna stay with us almost the
whole day today so we're gonna do some
surfing folks
we got a lot of stuff to get to there's
a lot of news uh as you guys know the
deutsche bank whistleblower was found
dead in la i believe that's the story
so we're going to go through we're going
to go through
and the clintons are are trending today
you know what's funny about the uh
whistleblower being dead
um you know the clintons can't kill that
you know they blame every single person
who dies on on hillary clinton she had
him murdered she had a murder but here
we have a whistleblower who could
possibly
possibly speak to the fact
possibly speak to the fact that donald
trump and vladimir putin and the
russians were laundering money to
through deutsche bank
and the whistleblower who knows that
stuff winds up dead
seems suspicious
same sex i don't know um trevor reed as
you guys know uh is coming home he has
been released by the russian government
speaking of vladimir putin that murder
is dictated in the russians they swapped
they did a prisoner swap today
apparently it was some drug russian drug
smuggler
um that we swapped with trevor reed so
and you know i'm willing i'm willing to
trade
drug smugglers
for for uh veterans and and heroes
american heroes so i'm i'm good with
that i think that's a good deal to be
made um
madeline albright's i think her funeral
is today uh kevin samuels i don't know
kevin samuels is but apparently he said
some stupid [ __ ]
so we're going to uh we're going to talk
about that there was uh there was a
business person in new york indicted by
the southern district of new york
on fraud charges no it's not donald
trump yet
but we're going to get to that story um
adam schiff is in the is in the is in
the news for a couple different reasons
so we'll get to that
uh the right wing is really pissed off
about
cancel culture canceling and blocking
even though they're the ones who are
actually participating in it
um again that the news of tesla losing
126 billion dollars in valuation because
elon musk is a [ __ ] idiot
uh yesterday
is in the news so we'll talk about that
bulgaria
is not receiving natural gas from russia
uh russians russia seems to be trying to
they seem to be trying to up the ruble
they seem to be trying to
inflate the ruble
so that their their population doesn't
get worried about their murderous
dictator taking over sovereign nations
um so we got that and then
we have lauren bobert doesn't know what
a democracy is she didn't look it up
like she can't [ __ ] google the word
democracy she can't google it like you
they're i mean you got the [ __ ]
machine in your hand right like the
google machine is in your hand you just
gotta switch from twitter to google or
duckduckgo for that man i don't give a
[ __ ] you can go dictionary.com where the
[ __ ] you want to go lauren
wherever you want to go bobo just just
switch over to some other app
actually even in the twitter app if
you're on iphone you can highlight a
word and say look up and it'll give you
it'll give you the [ __ ] navigation
definition
give you the definition of a word this
is brilliant type [ __ ]
right like dictionaries are new
like dictionaries or new technology or
some [ __ ]
she actually thinks she thinks
that a constitutional republic
cannot be a democracy these are really
[ __ ] boneheaded people holy actual
[ __ ]
how these people don't even know what
the definition of democracy is
that's where we're at folks there is a
person who has sworn an oath on the
constitution like they swore no to it
and they have no [ __ ] clue they have
no clue that a constitutional republic
is a form of democracy no [ __ ] idea
holy actual [ __ ]
i'm dead serious they she has no clue
we're gonna we're gonna see the tweet
and of course we're gonna drag her
and speaking of uh maga boneheads trump
supporters who don't know [ __ ] there is
a great new video from the trump rally
from good liars of course good liars
doing a service for all of us showing us
these
these boneheaded trump supporters at
these trump rallies and the [ __ ] that
they could possibly believe i don't even
know how it's possible that they believe
some of this [ __ ] i have no clue how
they
i it's baffling
this stuff is baffling
i just can't explain this [ __ ]
but we'll get there we'll get there so
we'll watch that video
but let's let's start let's go to the
tweety tweets and trendy trends you guys
know
that we surf the tweety tweets and
trendy trends the news of the day
and the big news that i want to talk
about is deutsche bank but also if you
heard
donald trump may have testified
in the state of new york so let's start
the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back to the tony
michaels podcast it is now time for the
[ __ ] list roundup we'll be round up all
the tweety tweets and trendy trends of
the day
oh boy there's it's been all over the
place this morning
the tweety tweets and the trendy trends
has been all over the place this morning
up and down in and out
[Music]
what do you guys think of the news today
i think there's a lot of news we missed
yesterday
right
um
with uh what it seems like and donald
trump may have testified is what it
seems like you know he was going to get
fined held in contempt for ten thousand
dollars a day
there's some news that he might have
testified that may be why that may be
why all this news is is caused for
distraction
but here is um
here is the timeline let's go through
the timeline here
[Music]
here's the uh
the video from let's make this bigger
from good liars here
you know good liars walter some of our
favorites
who who um
brave the trump rallies and they go um
talk to these people and find out the
[ __ ] that they believe and you know what
it seems like they're getting crazier
and crazier right doesn't it seem like
that to you
like the people that are showing up at
these rallies are getting nutty or
nuttier like they were nuttier than
squirrel turds for a long time but these
people are just whew they're way out
there
like they believe [ __ ] conspiracy
theories and [ __ ] that you just wouldn't
believe like last week we saw a woman
she thinks princess diana is still alive
she thinks she's still alive she's
running the world or some dumb [ __ ] i
don't know something something to do
with god and jesus and
guns and liberty and america and flag
and donald trump the king i don't know
some [ __ ] i can't figure it out
but um we're gonna watch this video and
and they don't talk about jfk junior but
jfk junior enters the chat in this video
i'll point it out uh when we get there
um
cat turd is in the hospital
i can't even believe i get to say that
sentence isn't that awesome cat turd is
in the hospital
uh cat turd as you guys know
or maybe you don't maybe you don't clear
the litter box enough
cat turd
is a conservative dumb [ __ ] who i
shouldn't even say concern he's a nazi
we we need to stop calling these people
republicans or conservatives they're not
republicans or conservatives
i mean tweeted um last night good night
everyone still in the hospital see you
tomorrow
but here is marjorie taylor green
telling the cat turd good night
this is real life i'm not [ __ ] you
this is real life i wouldn't [ __ ] you
you're my favorite turd not my cat turd
my favorite one
good night cat turd is she's she's
tweeting
and an account
that's called cat turd and i said
always weird to see a piece of [ __ ] wish
a cat turd good night
what the [ __ ] is happening this is real
life [ __ ]
like this is happening right out in the
open
and she's she's tweeting it because we
all know from the uh
marjorie perjury green
that she testified that she does not
have on a twitter account and she can't
tweet but she can because she's gotta
handle rep mtg she is tweeting at cat
turd from her congressional account
which means that this tweet right here
this one right here this reply here
that is now official congressional
record
that is our tweet
we
the people own that tweet
good night cat turd
what the [ __ ] you can't make this [ __ ]
up
no pun intended okay now here's the
breaking news on um
trump the daily beast as an article uh
jose jose says here breaking news and
the stunning deputy deposition
ex-president repeatedly admitted that he
and only he
oversaw the compensation of his co chief
operating officer matt calamari that is
very significant news that he and only
he
because cat matt
cat i'm stuck in the cat turd thing matt
calamari
is one of the ones that was receiving
the perks
that the trump organization
and alan weisselberg the cfo is indicted
criminally
on down in the uh manhattan da's office
so i bet the manhattan d.a is very
interested in the person who oversaw
that person's compensation
exclusively because he said he and only
problem is those untaxed corporate perks
are under investigation by the manhattan
d.a
as he points out here so that story is
going to be a big story that's probably
why we're not hearing about this i have
no idea why i have no idea why we're not
hearing about this story more yeah it
must be must be someone wants to
distract us hmm
could be
could be
all right i have a crazy video here for
you that i want to play eric swalwell
reposted it here
he says there's no more po being polite
our children are running for their lives
because republican block gun safety laws
republicans are the party of mass
shooters
uh
eric swalwell not mincing words this is
a very hard video to watch i'm gonna
turn it down just a bit um if you're
sensitive to
now no no one gets shot in this incident
which is good that's the news no one was
shot in this instant in incident
but um you're gonna watch and you should
show this to every single person that
you know that has children you should
show them this video
mayo good morning mayo good morning mayo
where you been good morning mayo um
but this is this may be hard to watch
for some of you so but we're not gonna
look away here we don't look away here
at the tony michaels podcast but i am
warning you uh there is children uh
extremely frightened for their lives in
this video no one is shot and at this
incident but that's not the point uh and
really honestly it goes right over
republicans and these 2am second
amendment boneheads uh
excuse the expression their heads goes
over goes over their heads they're
boneheads
but let's watch this video
hang on i got the sound i got the sound
messed up let's let's
there we go now i'm set let's back it up
and let's watch it
and you see it takes the children a
minute they're on the baseball field
they're playing a baseball game
they're playing a baseball game
in the middle of it
he's he's about to get a pitch
and the gunfire ensues
these children aren't aware of what's
going on they're concentrating on their
baseball game they're concentrating on
being children
let's watch
[Music]
so you see these children
crawling down on the baseball field and
fear
anyone who has children should have to
watch this video i believe get in front
of them if they're your friends if
they're your family they're your church
members community members people you
know in the pta put this video in front
of them
we cannot look away at this stuff this
is [ __ ] ridiculous and eric swalwell
makes a damn good point that because
they're trying
look they they make all kinds of [ __ ]
excuses about rights and and gun rights
and protection and protecting yourself
and good guy bad guy [ __ ] that's all a
bunch of [ __ ] the fact of the matter
is is it republicans in this country are
allowing are allowing gun manufacturers
to continue to manufacture these weapons
of war that are going to kill our
children
and they don't give a [ __ ]
because you know campaign funds
profits
bullets
bullets entering and exiting through
children are worth profits and campaign
funds to republicans it's [ __ ] gross
but it's the goddamn truth they don't
give two
flying [ __ ]
about your children and their safety
they don't give a [ __ ] they're gonna let
gun manufacturers continue to
manufacture weapons of war and sell them
to
to people who are off their rockers who
are willing to throw bullets anywhere
including into the bodies of children
and they say they're the [ __ ] parties
that are trying to save the kids get the
[ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ] that is
a bunch of [ __ ] they're trying to
they're trying to make sure that guns
can be slung towards your children
they're trying to sexualize your
children's gender they're trying to
miriam in tennessee and missouri they're
trying to ostracize kids from society
they're trying to criminalize
parents
of trans kids and lgbt community kids
they're trying to take their consent
away from your children
all the while making sure the gun
manufacturers have the ability to sell
weapons of war
that can send
red hot red hot ammo through your
children's bodies it's enough of this
[ __ ] and i said when will we in this
stupidity because it is us it's the
american people who are not stopping
this
the idea that oh well this will happen
anyways who gives a [ __ ] no that is all
a bunch of [ __ ] that's their
narrative
that is their narrative that all it
happens anyways so wouldn't you want
enough guns to shoot back
as if more bullets flying in the air is
the solution
we need to stop the gun manufacturers
from manufacturing
this
crisis
murdering our children
it's enough of this [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
enough of it now let me give eric
swalwell credit i already gave him
credit here i'm on a rant i'm pissed off
i don't even know when i'm giving credit
yeah
okay let's let's move back on to elon
musk the eye guy is really in the chat
really trying to tell everyone the
conspiracy theory of why why elon musk
is gonna buy it's gonna buy twitter he
may buy twitter he may buy twitter he
may i don't he's not he's not anybody
he's not getting my twitter um i said
who's the genius that lost a shitload of
cash today this [ __ ] guy look at this
guy i showed this picture yesterday look
at this [ __ ] guy does this look like
a guy who's gonna commit to anything he
couldn't even commit to a couple more
minutes for the barber to finish his
haircut flaked on his barber
come on give me a [ __ ] break
get me a break uh susan collins was in
the news because she said that she wants
trump back on twitter
i guess i don't know our our twitter
should let trump back on or some [ __ ] i
said does susan collins even know what
the [ __ ] twitter is
i i'm being serious i'm not joking here
it may sound like a joke but i'm not
joking does she does she even know what
the [ __ ] twitter is i have no idea i
wouldn't i could i couldn't tell you i
don't know if she's in collins
uh i think bad company here let's see
bat company uh gave us does susan
collins even know what the [ __ ] a susan
collins is
[Laughter]
that's great the susan collins even know
what a susan collins is i don't know i
it's a good question
it's a damn good question
um uh let's see did it did oh oh mark
meadows and kevin mccarthy are still in
the news oh baby
mort mark meadows text messages and a
hell of a lot more kevin mccarthy uh
phone conversations that were taped
there's tapes baby there's tapes
literally there's uh you can't
oh man
this is the party [ __ ] stupid the
party of [ __ ] stupid there's tapes of
kevin mccarthy basically
saying
oh trump bad insurrection bad we can't
have this this is nonsense i mean it
just it never ends and they're gonna get
worse and worse and worse here the tapes
that is the kevin mccarthy tapes are
gonna get worse and worse and worse for
him my question is my question is and
maybe i i think i put this in my drafts
i'm gonna tweet it out right now so you
folks don't steal it from me
my question is is is someone recording
kevin mccarthy's conversations like
right now
like right now is anyone else
wondering who's recording kevin
mccarthy's conversations because he's
having conversations on the phone
are they recording them now are we gonna
see
we're gonna see those i tweeted so mark
meadows got the text kevin mccarthy got
those tapes
who got the vids
who got the vids out there we need the
videos we need some video content here
at the tony michaels podcast
oh boy speaking of kevin mccarthy and
tapes here you go here's here's one that
rachel maddow played on her show let me
see uh it says mccarthy can't they take
their twitter accounts away too
um just listen here and to the end
listen to the end of kevin mcgarthy
and there's an issue with alabama barry
moore has said some some things today
even that we should look at honestly
what did barry say today
all right so he deleted his personal
twitter account but jamie dupree with
the atlanta journal
got screenshots um
he said about again
they're saying um they deleted their
twitter account
which is significant listening 22 hours
ago
wow we have more arrests for stealing a
podium on january 6th than we do for
stealing an election on november 3rd
atlanta philadelphia and detroit would
be places i recommend you start there's
video evidence of these crimes as well
election integrity matters
and then
um
moore also made this tweet on saturday
night as the u.s capitol police officer
who shot and killed a woman as he tried
to get into the lobby so he tweeted at
marjorie green and at neyral i
understand it was a black police officer
that shot the white female veteran you
know that doesn't fit the narrative
what
i i don't i don't know who says that has
makes that sound listen to that sound i
think they say [ __ ] and you tell me
listen in the shot the white female
veteran you know that doesn't fit the
narrative
what
and and maybe he's saying what but i
want to believe it's [ __ ] but it sounds
i don't know it's i don't know who it is
in there but what [ __ ] i don't know but
they're really they're they're really
pissed off that the republicans are a
bunch of crazy nut bag
wackadoos
they're like oh my god our party's full
of a bunch of squirrel turds they're
nutty and [ __ ] yeah no no
no [ __ ] shirt lock of course they are
you people have perpetuated this
i mean we see this week with madison
gawthorne just time after time after
time and more and more evidence and
really honestly someone points out here
elise stefanik is the leaker i don't
know lisa if that's true or not but what
i what i do probably know is true is
that the republicans are now trying to
destroy uh madison cawthorne and any any
trump humper out there
that would give him any kind of light a
day and they're really going to start to
clean house here because i think they're
realizing that this is not going to go
well for them in this midterm
because they're delivering everything we
need folks we just have to get the
messaging out there so people will go
vote against these [ __ ] seditious
republicans let's listen to the end here
of when kevin mccarthy realizes
that we should delete people's twitter
accounts listen
then oh oh
man
this isn't what we have to confront with
this
can't they take their twitter accounts
away too
can't they take their twitter accounts
away too
ah
rachel there can't they take their
twitter accounts away too oh my god
it really yeah it just it's it's getting
worse and worse and worse for the
republicans and the more and more
that steps forward the worse it gets i
mean we see madison catherine for this
for the second time yesterday get caught
in an airport with a loaded weapon
a loaded gun on his person
uh they they they only charged him with
a misdemeanor i guess because it's only
a misdemeanor
but oh my god it just
you just can't make this [ __ ] up you
just can't uh rachel bitikoffer our
favorite political strategist here
points out something about dc she said
dc has a one-party consent law that's
kind of shocking to me and she's
referring to
what permission you need to record a
phone call
she's very shocked that dc only has a
one party you'd think they would have a
two-party is what she's saying
oh here is our executive producer and
and
co-host gabe sanchez tweet about
oh looky there
elon
elon lost 126 billion he's real sad look
at that
uh obviously gabe
doctored the um
doctor the graphic here a bit with
elon's sad face but the truth is they
lost 126 billion yesterday and all at
the favor of elon musk
gabe says woof tesla wiped
roughly 126 billion off his valuation
today investors are not happy
with elon musk right now boy it really
it really i bet really and makes
people really encouraged and confident
that he could buy and run twitter
into the ground maybe i don't know
this is really dumb uh by the way
you can go watch
uh my commentary yesterday on elon
uh with this with this with this link
here
the super genius elon musk tank tesla by
100 billion of course at that point when
i tweeted this
because i tweeted this from the pod
account i un you know if you guys
haven't figured out sometimes i tweet
from the pod account sometimes gabe does
we should run like a running contest
where you guys guess in the reply of
who's tweeting that tweet from the
podcast account go follow the podcast
account you're going to want to follow
it because tomorrow
we're going to put out the bone head of
the week poll at tony michael's pod go
follow us there
so you don't miss the bonehead of the
week poll hey for all you new listeners
out there we run a poll every week about
the boneheads of the week
you guys decide who is the bonehead of
the week and i bet this guy's gonna end
up on the list
um you guys decide who the bonehead of
the week is and then on friday
in the second hour of the show me and
gabe sanchez my co-host and executive
producer we break down your vote
for the bonehead of the week so go
follow at tony michael's pod and join us
every week in voting for the bonehead of
the week and then join us on friday
as we break down the bone of the week
the good news about the bone end of the
week part of the show if you guys miss
it
if you can't watch it live no problem we
we splice it out and we re-air it and
post it on the youtube channel
over the weekend so you guys have a
chance to see it so go subscribe to the
youtube channel
if you're on facebook or anywhere else
if you're on youtube right now subscribe
to the facebook or excuse me the youtube
channel
you can go over to midas touch facebook
page we'll play bonehead of the week
there too so go go to the minus facebook
page also
and like subscribe there because we will
play the bonehead of the week on their
page
on the weekends as well
after the fact and i'm sure this guy's
gonna end up on the bone of the week but
what you should do
is when we tweet out from the tony
michaels podcast account try to guess
who's tweeting maybe we'll make that
like an ongoing little
game you guys guess
who's tweeting that edit
let's see what else do we have
oh here's some more tapes of kevin
mccarthy about matt gatz
oh this is a good one let's listen in
what kevin mccarthy had to say on
january 10th
it's only a few days after the
insurrection not even a week we're not
even to the point where donald trump is
possibly going to be impeached at this
point
but let's see what kevin mccarthy had to
say
about matt getz the accused child sex
trafficker the thing i want to bring up
and i'm making some phone calls to some
members
um
i just i just got something sent now
about newsmax something matt gates said
where he's
calling people's name by the way he's
saying the name wrong it's not gates i
wish people would stop it's gets
gets it's not gates
[Laughter]
i don't want to point that out i'm the
only one in the world that says it right
now saying an anti-trump in this type of
atmosphere um in some of the other
places this is this is serious stuff
people are doing that have to stop
um
so here you see steve scalise who is the
house republican whip
and if you're if you're not up on what
the house republican whip is it's
basically the third in charge kind of
thing
right they're the third in charge
so you have the house republican whip
steve scalise
gonna comment on
louis gohmert
and i believe mo brooks is who he's
talking about here
louie and mo on their comments
and then he says something about matt
getz comments and you gotta you gotta
listen really close because steve
scalise questions
rather it's illegal or not for them to
say some of the [ __ ] they're saying
listen louie's comments too a lot of
members have said
some real concerning things about did
they face did they say something today
too
i said louis was that i mean um
i mean here's the thing they're like
like oh my god did they say did these
nut bags say something please shut them
the [ __ ] up and they they're they're
they claim liberals want to cancel
people and they're like jesus christ we
need to shut these [ __ ] idiots up
these wackadoos
these nut bags in our party and they're
the ones that support trump the most if
you're unaware
out there of how the republican
leadership views donald trump they think
he's a [ __ ] chucklehead and they
think anyone who follows him is a
[ __ ] dumbass and they're a loudmouth
and they need to shut the [ __ ] up
they don't say that [ __ ] in public
because they're weak they're cowards
steve scalise and kevin mccarthy are
[ __ ] cowards that they won't say that
[ __ ] in public but they're thinking it
moe was at the rally and we're kicking
ass and taking names thing at the trump
rally uh well these are the things that
were they kicked out
i think this is okay what did gates say
specifically i just saw that on twitter
someone just said um gonzalez just sent
it to me so i'm calling gates i'm
explaining to him
i don't know what he ever say but i'm
gonna have some other people call him
too but the nature of what if i'm
getting briefing i'm gonna get another
one from the fbi tomorrow
uh this is serious [ __ ] to cut this out
yeah that's that's that's that's
i mean it's potentially illegal what are
you doing it's potential potentially
illegal is what he's doing that is a
quote
from steve scalise
the republican house whip
saying
it's potentially illegal hey we have one
of the biggest mad gats fans here with
us right now um
joining us is our
co-host and executive producer and
matt matt gatz fan club president oh
yeah is that right is that right do you
do you run a matte gadget fan club well
uh
it's like the opposite of a fan club oh
it's like a haters club oh okay it's a
hater okay that's yeah yeah yeah yeah
i'm like you've got you've done a few
videos about matt gadge you've done a
video right yeah i've i've put him in
hell i've had him caught by chris hanson
yeah which
normal typical [ __ ] that matt gatz would
do right right are you have you caught
this tape where steve scalise says this
where he says yeah that's that's i mean
it's potentially illegal now steve
scalise does not think this is going to
get released right like when he's saying
this out loud on january 10 2021 just a
few days after the insurrection he has
no idea that this is going to be
released and if you did if he did he
wouldn't be saying this [ __ ] but he
doesn't think it's going to be released
so he says out loud that yeah it's
potentially illegal which is
just not really surprising it's not
stunning at all that these people are
saying one thing in private and doing
another in public yeah well at this at
this point you know i
it's like
you know i think you had a tweet
yesterday where it's like oh they got
the tapes we got the the
the tweets the tapes what was the other
one you said and then who's got the vids
oh yeah who's got the vids yeah who's
got the vids yeah i mean that's what i'm
waiting on is
i know there's probably video i mean
like in all these scenarios you look at
these people and they said something and
then
you know
without a doubt they
they incriminate themselves they're not
they're not the smartest people let's
just put it that way right like that
that is a good good man
right right they they suck at cooing
well you know the the craziest part
about it all is like the stupid ones
like the matt gets the marjorie jay the
greens the lauren bobert doesn't even
know what the word democracy means this
morning we're gonna go through that but
because i know you're you also have a
lauren bobert fan club as well um but uh
you're the maybe you're the vice
president of that one maybe not yeah
yeah but but but anyway anyways anyways
uh
they are they are the bone-headedness
[ __ ] that you could possibly pick out
to be members of congress but the
craziest part is is here's steve scalise
and kevin mccarthy who are in leadership
who are supposed to be the ones holding
it together and having some sort of a
brain
and they can't even [ __ ] figure it
out like literally they're they're
flabbergasted and they're like what do
we do how do we how do we keep our
caucus in order i mean and it's like
well you chose trump
in 2016. you guys did that you [ __ ]
this up way back when this isn't like a
thing that's just now happened and
they're still continuing this process of
being sycophants to this fool yeah i
mean they they made their bed now they
got to sleep in it right they allowed
trump to get to the power of the level
that he was at and they were totally
fine with it and they never really had
any objection you know of course
obviously they they
expressed some
um
kind of disappointment around january
6th but then that quickly washed away
within a couple weeks
um
but now
you know you look at these people who
are
and you got marger taylor green madison
cawthorn matt gates um
yeah all
these boneheads but like you it's if if
you create you know it's the same it's
the same [ __ ] that happens at a company
right like if you allow a toxic
environment to happen right you have the
people like you look at you know what
happened at uh wework or uber or any of
these other startups or yesterday at
tesla i'm just kidding right yeah
exactly if you well actually tesla is a
good example of a toxic work environment
as well well we'll get into that here
right and so if you create a toxic work
environment because it's created by
toxic individuals then you're going to
just
repeat the same issues and perpetuate
that same problem and so it's just going
to
unless you take the the evil the root of
the evil out or or the issue you're just
only going to allow it to go longer in
spread and that's what happened with the
republican party like you see this as
it's hap let's just say it's happened
since nixon all right but in the last
obviously decade or so [ __ ] has really
hit the fan
and the more and more they allow and the
more the more they allow to like push
the envelope and cross the line and and
kind of do questionable things and when
people are like oh yeah that that seemed
that you know what that wasn't totally
okay but in this one moment we'll allow
it and they just keep testing and
testing and testing and that's where you
see we've gone to january 6 and even
beyond that and then these tapes come
out about things that are being said
there might be people in the in the
republican party who who don't think
highly of others
but they created that environment
they are the ones that allowed it to
flourish and grow
and just like take it's like weeds in a
garden they allowed it to kill or
cocaine at a sex orgy i mean it could be
you know but yeah here's the throne
here's the thing the reason why i now
believe why liz cheney because there's
been a lot of speculation on why liz
cheney and adam kinzinger you know kind
of flipped on the republican party and
went with the troop the true narrative
as opposed to the the [ __ ] lies
right
because liz janey and adam kinser are
likely to show up on these tapes and
they probably knew that and they made
the decision
in the moment to say you know what when
these tapes come out there's going to be
so damaging to my reputation that i
would rather endure the [ __ ]
for now and then be vindicated when the
tapes come out because well she's liz
cheney's already on the team right right
now exactly because she was in
leadership she was in leadership right
right and we don't know to the extent of
like maybe they say some more
disparaging things or they it shows a a
poor light on them
but she we know for a fact that she's
already on the tapes maybe there's more
obviously you know uh
ev they and i you know the other thing
too is
i don't know how this audio is being
released right if they're just you know
the the publishers like all right now
here's an audio like here's an audio
here's another they were released to
jonathan martin and alexander burns for
this book
right this this is the tapes that they
use to confirm
the the the parts of the book that
they're writing in this this will not
pass because that's what kevin mccarthy
said oh that's a lie that books a lie
you know it's it's a it's a thing they
do
on odd automation right when a book
comes out and tells the truth oh that's
a lie you can't prove it you don't have
a source so jonathan martin and
alexander burns is like oh really we
don't have a source well we were given
these tapes so now they're just drip
drip dripping it and honestly they're
doing a huge service here
we always talk about how people hold
hold information for books but really in
the sake of our democracy at this moment
in time for these tapes to be being
released when republican primaries are
as hot as they are right now like we're
gonna have the ohio senate candidate
primary within the next week i believe
it's next tuesday
if that's [ __ ] huge eric greitens is
running in the primary missouri that's
going to happen soon so all this stuff
is happening and republicans
not democrats are the ones who are
wanting to damage trumpism they're
wanting to damage trumpism because they
see the threat of them not winning the
senate and the house
if trump candidates get elected into the
primary and they're on the general
ballot during the midterm they're going
to [ __ ] lose
hear my words out there if you're
listening
republicans are terrified for
trump-humping idiots to end up on the
ballot for the general midterm election
they are terrified of it because they
know they will lose and the reason why
they'll lose is because they're just
[ __ ] way out there
they republicans the other day if you
were in the republican party who wants
to win you loved watching marjorie
taylor greene say some dumb stupid [ __ ]
on the stand last week because it
damages her politically you love to leak
[ __ ] about madison gothard you love that
he got caught in an airport yesterday
with a loaded gun if you're a republican
you love that [ __ ] because that does not
support the trump narrative and the tr
and trumpism in this country and that's
what the republicans want they want
their party back they want their thin
veiled fascism back they don't want this
outright nazi let's go brandon nazi [ __ ]
so um no no no
100 on the dot and i think the other
thing too is is that they
there is so much of
uh you know like okay for instance you
talked about you know these
trump-humping uh politicians right you
look if you looked at the debate that
was happening in pennsylvania for the
u.s senate seat all of them except one
of the candidates was like president
trump you know you've got oz saying
president trump endorsed me well i just
spoke to president trump the other day
and president trump made america great
and president trump this it's like you
know out of the seven or six or so
people that are on the on the stage
debating
uh a
majority of them are trying to push
pro-trump narrative because in their
mind they see it as like the only way
for me to have a chance right now is is
to build on the momentum that trump is
coming back in 2024 or
that trump's voice uh is the is the
final has a final say right and there's
only you know one or two people on that
floor or on that on that stage that were
willing to say
the opposite of that or willing to say
something was different so
i mean i think i think the calculation
is that they want to be on the ballot
and right now in this moment the way to
get on the ballot right
with trump because that's where the
voters are right right so their
constituents are in a place where
they're ready to vote for trumpism but
the problem is the general midterm not
not this primary their problem is the
general election in the midterm and you
could easily vote against trumpism and
that's the problem you could easily see
the flip of a switch you know as much as
like you know trump was for mo brooks
and then was against mo brooks like you
could easily see let's say that
something does happen with trump right
he
uh
you know the fines of contempt gets so
high he actually has to go in and do
this and do that with isn't the news
that he went and testified isn't that oh
did he is that right
he testified that that he and only he
was in charge of matt calamari's salary
or his compensation i believe that's
part of this testimony to the new york
ag i believe donald trump can't afford
donald trump can't afford ten thousand
dollars a day he knows he'll go broke
he'll know he know the jig is up he
knows that his supporters will find out
he is broke as a [ __ ] joke because
that's the truth donald trump is not
rich he's [ __ ] broke and that is the
facade that's the facade he's been
trying to hold up for years and he's
still trying to hold up that's what
these maga rallies are about these manga
rallies are not for him to run in 2024
it's to take his supporters money which
we're gonna look at a video i want you
to see it's hilarious oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah no that's right because i
remember yes exactly because i yes i
remember reading a
uh i think the very first date the very
first day late in that day where he was
gonna be fine ten thousand dollars he
test he he well he didn't do it in
person they sent it in they they
submitted his testimony yeah so i don't
know if he he testified um in a building
somewhere and they videotaped it and
sent anything like that i'm not real
sure what testimony they sent in but and
i'm sure it was minimal at best
with trump but they sent in some sort of
testimony that the ag's office agreed to
take and i think that that was
substantial enough are we sure it's not
i like i wanna i feel like well i don't
know testimony but i don't know if
someone can confirm is it from a
previous testimony or is it from this
week well you know what like i saw
here's the thing we have kfa gonna join
us um i i've got her on text right now
she said um great we are talking now
i'm i'm live texting
um dude we are streaming live texting
live tweeting just hop on
when
you're ready i'm gonna email her here
uh email and text email yeah i'll email
a dude i'll tell you what i would fax it
if i had a fax machine but i i don't
know i do have a fax machine okay
okay well look it's it was it was tied
in with the printer
all right well that that's the same here
that's why i don't have a hooked i don't
have a phone line like in the house i
don't have a phone line you don't have a
phone line i don't have i don't know i
don't have one so i couldn't backstage i
couldn't fax even if i wanted to yeah
i'm gonna email uh karen here the the
link um because we want her to join us
uh for this conversation
about the
uh and she can give us the lowdown of
what this testimony is and maybe she can
shed some light on the story
about the the testimony that was
submitted by donald trump and his team
and we'll find out if that has anything
to do
with uh so i think i got it here i think
she'll be joining us let's see copy
okay i think we're i think we're going
to be good to go with you got it you
figured it out you know how to do it
easy easy easy there the executive
producer who can't who can't run the
microphone you know i really can't run
it it really is real i just really was
rich you know i just don't wanna you
know there's a lot of things i'm doing
in the background before i come on the
show oh oh there's a lot of things
you're doing in the back yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah not like physically you
know physically
does nothing you know yeah he's not
running
i we we appreciate uh the the the talent
that our that of art that gabe has for
graphics speaking of that let's bring
this up on the screen i do want to say
uh thank you to mj for the super oh yes
yes thank you very much spot on cheeto
dust mobster is broke that's what he's
hiding that's what he's hiding folks
that really is what he's adding i mean
didn't he tell ivanka at one point he
you know the story as it goes is ivanka
and him were on the street and he
pointed to a homeless man and he said
that man is richer than me
right isn't that how the story goes well
i don't know something about him
wanting to
have sex with her that's what i heard
well yeah i know that's oh that's a this
is a different name this is their oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm sorry i i i i
missed where if they weren't father and
daughter they would be having sex i
thought that was the story to talk about
um you made this graphic let's get the
uh
i did i made a graphic
look at this
now now this is a real graphic you just
added a few things here right
uh yeah so that is the actual uh
that was yesterday at whatever time uh
let's see
the time stamp for me here is 15 hours
ago
so
15 hours ago is when you listen i don't
i can't do the math on this but 15 hours
ago come on man
she's louise
yeah it was yesterday evening no it was
before i left it was yeah it was like
around six or seven before before you
went to your soda streaming party is it
exactly i met up with a bunch of
sodastream enthusiasts why i know i know
yesterday was taco tuesday and you
planned on going somewhere tacos and
stream soda so i figured maybe you guys
had like a yeah well you know you know
it's a little bit more like a stream off
is that what you call it when you go to
your competition i got stream off is it
uh well yeah sure you probably stream
you go you go stream off with them i
don't know we go yeah just go yeah just
trying to snowball here anyway yeah
anyways back back to the graphic before
you went to stream off yeah yeah so the
whole day i was watching this stock just
go down and down and down and down right
and by the end of the day i was like all
right i think it's at a it's at a low
enough point and uh you know verified
the numbers here and it was roughly
around 126 billion dollars in uh
market value that was lost in a day
now
with that there are other things that
need to be mentioned here now people are
like oh elon musk he's a billionaire
yeah he's a billionaire he has uh
billions of dollars in in net worth
the breakdown
uh is
for tesla he has
131
billion dollars in tesla options it's
about 74.9 billion and spacex it's 40.3
and twitter it's 3.6 based on the
current uh current stock that he owns
right now the boring company is 3.4 now
the cash and cash equivalents like the
liquid assets is only 2.8 billion now
still he's not wait a way to say wait a
second wait a second so you're saying
the cash on hand the actual like real
cash and stuff that he as like if you
were to be like hey i need the money
right now is only 2.8 billion so what
you're saying is if he wanted to put the
cash in duffel bags to give to someone
he could only get a couple billion
dollars yep that's it only a couple
billion dollars you know uh and so just
not that much liquid yeah yeah but
remember elon musk has agreed to a 44
44 to 45 billion dollar uh deal to
to buy twitter that's what he's that's
that's that's the front yes that's what
they've agreed to right they and um
the issue here is that he doesn't have
44 billion
he doesn't even have the 22 billion
because he's going in 50 percent with i
think uh
with vanguard is the other one that's
also wait a second you're telling me
that elon musk hasn't been gonna be the
owner he's gonna be the half owner is
that what you're telling me essentially
yeah well i mean by taking you know
you're you're taking you're getting
money from someone else's alone but yes
he's not the full 100 owner technically
because he's got to put someone else's
money into it oh so so he's not as he's
not as rich as he says he is exactly so
he's got about 21 to 22 billion that
he's got to throw into the pot here now
again he's only got 2.8 billion in cash
and cash equivalents that seems a little
short of 22. that's it
now the other that money the remainder
the delta there between you know a
little shy of three and about 22 billion
has to come from somewhere right right
so how does somebody get that money
well he's got uh
a stake in tesla and the boring company
and spacex but a majority of the money
obviously is coming out of uh tesla
right because spacex is only 40 billion
jesus christ 40 billion and the boring
company is 3.4 but tesla's 131 billion
now
with that
he's got to sell something right he's
got to figure out how to get that's got
to get the cash from one place to the
other he has to say like listen i'm
bringing 44 billion total but i got to
come up with 22 billion of my own money
and i'm not going to sell everything i
have my liquid assets so that means i
got to sell options or i got to sell my
stock in tesla which means that the
value of tesla uh is it's going to be um
lowered because the investor's
confidence in the company will also go
down now theoretically the board could
also vote uh no confidence on on elon
musk and say that he's not fit to be ceo
which means that they would have to
remove him as the ceo which means that
in this world of like uh if this was
made into a movie or something he would
lose his position at the company a ceo
and he would potentially lose his uh his
stake in in becoming the new owner of
twitter now with all that being said
the thing that people don't also know is
that there is a one
billion dollar termination fee if either
party
leaves the deal from what has been
agreed
that party has to pay a billion dollars
to you know to the other right so it's a
termination
if they flake which means if they didn't
if they didn't like finish the haircut
in other words right exactly twitter
right now has nothing to lose they have
everything to gain because it's almost
like they knew that from the beginning
right right i mean i don't you know
whoever put this agreement in place was
like great you know if someone's going
to balk and walk away from this they got
to pay up and we got to make it worth
our val
our time right and so
uh kind of the final thought on this is
just to remember
again the money's got to come from
summer which means it has to come from
other companies which is why investors
are selling their their stock while the
price of check
while the price of tesla was higher and
also because they have a lack of
confidence in this uh in this leader of
the company and now that he's going in
for twitter for 44 billion or 22 billion
they look at this and say
well
we don't know if it's really going to
happen or not so we have this this
termination fee in there now again
twitter has nothing to lose they have
everything to gain
they're going to be paid no matter what
whether it's a billion dollars from a
fee
or it's 44 billion dollars in the actual
buyout so they're getting money in the
bees yeah they're gonna get money no
matter what right and and right now
elon
has to step up to the plate and actually
go forward with this or else
he's
he doesn't own twitter potentially loses
his position at tesla and it all falls
down i mean honestly honestly he he he
almost destroyed tesla yesterday just by
making this move and i wouldn't be
surprised i wouldn't be surprised uh
someone surmised this i think on the
internet maybe him pissing off bill
gates less than a week ago maybe bill
gates shorted the tesla stock like just
totally tanked it um by short i mean
he had a short position on it elon
called him out for it and all of the
elon stands and i've had a ton of hate
on twitter for this oh you're hating
they're hating on me today in our
comments our even our listeners are
really are really butthurt that we don't
think i don't think elon's going to buy
twitter i don't think he's going to so i
don't i still think it's a 50 50 but you
know
i don't even i don't even give him 50 50
on this shot because here's the fact of
the matter and you pointed it out
yesterday and we talked about it elon
musk
is notorious for saying a big making a
big huge promise and not even delivering
on a sliver of it and this promise that
he's going to deliver this 44 billion
dollars for twitter that is a huge
[ __ ] promise that he made and the
fact that twitter smart people not elon
musk he's not smart he lost 26 if
i had this conversation and that's also
that's also just the valuation of tesla
that's not including right his own net
worth right so what do you think
somebody said was in the double digits
20 billion or something right so here's
the thing yesterday i had a conversation
with my son and i asked him about elon
musk and he said he said the reason why
he's smart is because he's so rich and i
s and i went to my son
last night when i found out he lost 120
i said the guy lost 126 billion how
smart is that and and he kind of changed
his tune and everyone should realize
that elon musk
probably got punked here i was saying
the other day that elon musk is punking
people on the internet
i think twitter and the investors and a
lot of really smart people who know the
financing looked at this and went he's
going to lose big and we can gain and
that's what happens in capitalism a
corporation will devour another
corporation if it means they make a ton
of money
if if this if the shareholders at
twitter could gain a billion dollars
from elon musk because he's a bonehead
that board would take that bet and i i
almost i almost would say that's the bet
they're taking because it's an easy bet
against elon that he will that he will
flake on this deal he will flake oh the
last thing i want to i want to mention
about this is uh you know
for for a person who is pro free speech
right there's a lot of things that go
against what he has done and in the
contract the agreement there when when
you're in this position you're not
supposed to have any disparaging remarks
about the company or those who work at
the company he's already violated the
contract and that is there's a you know
there's screenshots and and and tweets
of of legal counsel
and so uh
basically he's already again he's
already violated the contract in terms
of making any remarks that would go
against the company in which you wish to
purchase and are having this contract in
agreement with so there's already that
that's happening there there's the other
aspect of like hit the market value the
lack of confidence with investors at
tesla uh the potential removal of him as
ceo maybe that might happen but then
also looking at just the overall deal
he has to go through with it or else he
has to pay out a billion for the
termination he has to prove to investors
that he actually can run tesla without
removing value from the company and
taken out of the of of the market um
it's a it's a it's not a win-win it
really becomes a lose-lose at this point
for for elon so
i mean it's not a
not a great position that he's put
himself in to own the libs but [ __ ] you
know yeah really own the legs on this on
the lips own the lips elon own the lips
and get and get on yourself um i want to
go back to the story that we were
talking about earlier um when we were
talking about the the deposition of
donald trump uh about the coo of the
trump organization his name is matt
calamari
um
he sounds delicious to be honest with
you i don't know i like calamari
little marinara sauce maybe well maybe
maybe i'm i'm a calamari fan that's one
of the only seafoods that i kind of like
is calamari he matt sounds delicious
he's not though he's it seems as if um
he may be tied up in this whole criminal
uh civil
thing with the uh new york ag and the
manhattan d.a there's problems with this
investigation and we're bringing on our
favorite legal expert here uh karen
agnipolo from legal af karen how are you
are you here hi yeah
can you hear me i can i can we can hear
you guys how are you thanks for having
me on again well i i know this story
came up last night and i was really
unsure what this story was and i figured
the best person to ask that i know is
kfa of illegal af and i know you guys
are probably going to have an episode
today um are you guys you guys are
airing uh legal af because it's every
wednesday right that you guys aired yeah
we have an episode dropping tonight at 8
eastern
is this is this maybe part of the
subject matter or not or not you know
it's actually not part of this
then maybe we're breaking kfa news here
with her analysis on
on on this story so what do you think
about this story is this deposition uh
one that he's submitted to try to fend
off this contempt charge of ten thousand
dollars a day or is this something
completely different this is something
completely different so
i'll start this with the caveat that i
literally this dropped
just recently last night i believe
and so hopefully i'm going to get all
this right i didn't i i didn't have a
chance to prepare the way i normally
would prepare when discussing something
so if i get something slightly wrong i
apologize
i've already been wrong about this story
i assume that maybe this was a
submission
of to to fend off the ten thousand
dollar uh contempt charge um that
they're the the the fine that they're
going to find him per day because that
fine seems to still be racking up so
okay well great well great i hope that
you'll be back still racking up the ten
thousand dollars a day okay good we
should start up we should have like a
thermometer you know yeah
yeah we could do that we could do that i
know i grabbed a
yeah yeah so maybe today maybe tomorrow
we'll have a new one for every day that
it's been yeah okay we'll we'll just
keep adding on to the graphic so tell us
what this is though what do you
understand about this
about this deposition did he did he give
a deposition in person or did they
submit it in writing i believe he gave a
deposition in person i believe there
might be a video tape um so what's so
what's interesting here
um is that this is a case a case that
certainly wasn't on my radar screen and
i had no idea about um it's an
individual who
was assaulted in front of trump tower in
new york city
uh by his kind of security guard so when
trump was running uh for office he made
all kinds of you know terrible terrible
comments and statements you know um
about
you know mexicans and you know kind of
all all that stuff that he said um you
know that that were that were very
negative and then he was running for
office and so people decided to protest
uh you know when he was saying that the
mexicans were rapists and killers do you
remember that when he was sort of
how could i forget it was like a 2015
speech yeah it was terrible so
there's a queen's resident in queens is
a county in new york um in new york city
uh it's it's next it's near brooklyn and
manhattan and there's a queens resident
named ephron galicia
and he and others decided to protest
this you know the fact that that
this man was running for president in
front of trump tile uh trump tower which
is located in new york city and it was
to kind of highlight the racism in these
statements and you know and to kind of
show you know how terrible of a person
donald trump is
well donald trump pretty easy pretty
easy i mean yeah yeah really he does it
a lot right he's a very great case for
himself but donald trump has security
you know has his bodyguards and security
guards etc is this bodyguard is the name
keith schiller i think is the name is
that is that who this this bodyguard is
i think that's the one
this is calamari this has to do with
that with an individual so he's the he's
the one who is his personal bodyguard
i think i think again
um i think i think trump
i think he once served as trump's
bodyguard and it's because
this is weird so it interestingly trump
saw
calamari
tackle a bunch of hecklers in a tennis
match in 1981
and
he therefore was so impressed by this
individual's course no tackling of
hecklers that he decided to hire him as
his personal bodyguard which he i'm sure
he talks about as like a celebration you
know like somehow that's like a badge of
honor anyway he rose through the ranks
and had various jobs and i think his son
calamari jr even works there i don't
know what position they held or you know
or what he had to do with it um
but he they were both very much
employed by the trump organization but
so anyway the bodyguard and i don't know
who it was in uh in um i'm sorry the
security guards bodyguards whatever you
want to call them at this uh protest in
front of trump tower
basically um
you know got into some kind of a scuffle
with individuals including the plaintiff
here you know who's suing trump because
of that that scuffle you know i don't
know if it was a fight i don't know you
know if property was destroyed i don't
know if somebody was injured i'm not
really sure i guess they manhandled them
is is the allegation
and um and you know that's this this is
a civil suit
that this individual mr galicia is
is bringing against um
bringing against donald trump and
the
trump organization
for
roughing them up at a
protest that the first amendment allows
mr galicia and the other people who are
there to to do i mean you know our
constitution the first amendment allows
for peaceful protests and so you can't
just be
um you can't just because you don't like
it you can't be manhandled and roughed
up so basically he's bringing a civil
suit and it's like i said it's something
i don't think it's on anyone's radar
it's just sort of being handled on its
own and has nothing to do with the
attorney general tish james it has
nothing to do with the district attorney
sy vance the former district attorney or
the current district attorney alvin
bragg it has nothing to do with federal
prosecutions or federal civil matters
this is just a private citizen
bringing
a civil matter against um one of the
many many many cases against donald
trump well he
you know and and i say that it is so
separate because both he and his lawyers
i guess didn't really think about how
what he says during the course of this
um
other civil matter could impact the
cases uh that are pending against him by
whether it's alvin bragg or tish james
and so he it was um
he basically sat for this deposition
and this was a while ago it wasn't
recent but uh
apparently um
it was i think it was over a year ago
sometime in 2021 and basically as part
of the deposition you know there was
lots and lots of questioning and i don't
really know because i haven't seen the
the deposition
uh but he part of the questioning had to
do with mr calamari uh in particular
calamari senior but also calamari junior
and
over and over again he would was asked
the president um donald trump was asked
at the time you know about the
compensation
of uh the of calamari senior who was
you're right i'm looking at the article
now he was the family company's chief
operating officer um at one point or
maybe still is what do i know um
and he kept saying when trump was asked
who oversaw his compensation who was in
charge of the compensation trump just
repeatedly kept saying it was him he was
the one who had authority over his
compensation uh etc and it was him and
he was the one in charge he was then one
involved and and i'm sure he was
thinking about his answers to that
question in the context of this limited
case this case you know involving these
protesters but what's interesting is
yesterday
uh his the the transcript of this
deposition was filed with the court
which um which is something that happens
in these in these legal cases you file
the transcripts therefore it makes it
public and available for everyone to see
which is why it's coming out in the news
now
because people are are really stunned by
the answers he gave and and you know a
daily beast article um uh just came out
and is sort of talking about it you know
i i think it came out uh today this
daily beast our article was published
and it's working here's the uh jose has
it here here's the um here's the tweet
that i had that i yeah
here it is here and you know it's
interesting a couple lawyer what what
made my what made me kind of you know
perk up a little bit when when you read
things like this without sort of you
know again i haven't read the deposition
myself i haven't read the filings myself
this i learned about this when this
article came out uh today frankly and
was reading about it but what really
kind of what i thought was interesting
was was there's comments by two lawyers
in here both of whom i know quite well
and have worked with very for for many
many many years uh john moscow who's a
former prosecutor with the manhattan
da's office and he was there for three
decades i think
and he was there for a very long time
he's a very well respected
former prosecutor and now a private
practitioner
but he knows all about kind of how how
white-collar cases occur and tax cases
etc and um so does adam kaufman who's
the other lawyer who was the former
chief of the investigation division um
at the manhattan da's office i worked
with him for many many years and again
is now a very respected attorney in
private practice um and really an expert
in in these types of matters both of
them are and and both of them said you
know that that um that you know this
that that these admissions uh by
trump that he only and he and only he
was in charge about uh of of these sort
of um compensation packages with
calamari
and that he was the one who made all the
decisions that that could have extreme
consequences and those are my words not
theirs but but certainly significant
consequences in any potential whether
it's prosecution of donald trump or uh
or the civil matter against donald trump
and and because you know because having
he donald trump being the individual who
is in charge of that really opens him up
to potential liability for the um you
know for the fact that perhaps these
could be you know fringe benefits that
weren't claimed on taxes for example
you know any sort of allegations like
that um
you know these are these are sort of
newly available statements that you know
you could use in the grand jury uh if
you're trying to indict
trump for for example an illegal payment
scheme you know which is kind of the
charges that they've i mean part of
this um current the current case so so
the manhattan da's office does have
a prosecution this is this was brought
by sy vance um before he left who is
your former boss correct my former boss
correct um he did bring charges against
the trump organization and weisselberg
who is i think the chief executive
officer i think the chief financial yes
apologies thank you i knew he was a
chief something officer
they're all they're all chiefs up there
right and everyone was hoping
weisselberg would flip and and cooperate
against trump which he has been widely
reported has not um
this now now the case is being handled
by alvin bragg as the current district
attorney this could potentially be what
he needs to
uh
bring a case against donald trump i mean
this could be
you know because these statements don't
forget even if even if calamari
won't testify against trump these
statements might be admissible against
trump because there's even though
they're here saying even though they're
out of court um
there's an exception to the hearsay rule
that statements that are made against
your pecuniary or penal interest you
know so it's against your interest there
you're kind of most people would take
the fifth you know um the fifth
amendment privilege against
self-incrimination uh before answering
cases that are against your um criminal
interest but in this particular instance
trump didn't he he answered all the
questions and in fact widely celebrated
after this deposition that he answered
every question and i think it's because
he didn't realize or recognize or
appreciate uh what he was saying and how
it could be used against him in another
it's sort of the law of unintended
consequences in another case so i could
see alvin bragg
who still has open investigations
into donald trump going and who i think
you know
one could surmise is under a little bit
of pressure to
bring charges against donald trump given
given the the big noisy public
resignation by um
by the two prosecutors recently mark
comarance and carrie dunn who were
leading the other
part of the trump um
trump investigation you know the one
about real estate valuations
um so you know this could be what
exactly what alvin bragg needs in order
to bring a case against trump who knows
all i don't know if this is going to be
the thing but it just feels like and
seems like the circle's tightening
around him and this is just one more
thing that could be used against him uh
and i don't think i think he just missed
it he and his lawyers and didn't realize
it when they answered it
right
go ahead so is new york unique in this
rule of using uh testimony from another
case that's potentially admissible or is
this kind of universal yeah this is
universal this is a widely recognized
hearsay exception
um you know that that can be that right
because at the time i mean there i guess
uh was it i guess was it publicly known
that cy vance was investigating trump
for the overvaluation of property
and fraud or was it kind of like and i
believe go ahead i believe that when
this deposition happened yeah
it looks like it was in october of 2021
and by then everybody knew
okay um about about so so what we're
relying on here is that the buffoonery
of donald trump um which is normally the
thing that puts his ass in a ringer for
lack of a better term um most of the
time gets him by the shortened curlies
as my my dad would say i mean this is
this is the thing that really people are
discounting about n not the prosecution
or the the grand juries about donald
trump himself is that this guy really
does think
he can do no wrong and he can i mean he
said he had
he said he could shoot someone on on
fifth avenue and and get away with it
and i feel like it's that it's that
hubris
it's it is that you know uh icarus yeah
buffoonery and and hubris that i think
will be you know hopefully will be the
ultimate demise of trump where he's like
oh i answered all questions four and a
half hours i answered everything i
answered them perfectly i answered them
exactly how that you know and then it's
like oh you actually it was perfect
self-incrimination right yeah i
i was the one i'm the one who did it all
i take credit and you're like oh you
dumbass just right hopefully gave the
the prosecution what they needed but i
mean i mean that's that's in a nutshell
but really
what has to happen if alan bragg is
going to use
you know tell us about the mechanisms
here because i think a lot of people
fail to realize that there's a there's
you know you can yell and scream about
something all you want and i do every
day but there is actual mechanisms here
so how does how does alan bragg as the
manhattan d.a
take this deposition from this other
case how does he get it in front of his
grand jury if he wants to to bring more
indictment charges because that's the
thing that everyone fails to realize the
trump organization is under criminal
indictment that the company that trump
owns is criminally charged and the cfo
is criminally charged at this i mean
also you know the previous organ like he
has other organizations that have either
one been bankrupt or the organization
itself the foundation has also been
uh charged or was charged and had to pay
fines for so it's like
there is never a property that trump
owns that he will not destroy himself in
some way shape or form right bankruptcy
or legal uh
legal kind of uh issues you know so it's
so how does alan bragg get this this
this testimony how does he get that into
the hands of the grand jury to make a
decision
so
there's a couple of different ways so
one is he could add it to
he could use it as evidence in the
current case that he has um against the
trump organization or and weisler and
you know perhaps
this is evidence that could be used in
that case just supporting the current
charges that are there
and it depends if it was a video he then
would use the actual video if not he
could get um he could get a certified
copy of the transcripts and and then
call the the whoever the transcriber is
to um you know to to the stand that who
would testify and say yes i you know
took this down and and this is a you
know an accurate copy and it was this
date it was donald trump you know all
that kind of stuff there's there's sort
of foundational ways to do it it just
depends on on the form that it's in and
i'm not exactly sure what that form is
but a couple of other things could be
done um
i think that um
there seems to be a suggestion
that uh
that
calamari was paid
um
in sort of perks that he did not pay
taxes on you know like here's a car
here's an apartment and here's private
school and whatever i don't know what
his particular perks were but those are
the types of perks that
that trump was known to to give out and
then not um
and then and then you know you don't pay
taxes on it but it's really income
so i guess uh alvin bragg could try to
prosecute um mr calamari for those um
similarly as he's doing to weisselberg
and then
hope that he will testify and flip
against trump
and i suppose the third way would be
just to
prosecute trump directly
based on this evidence uh
i think he needs more than than just
this testimony to bring a case but i do
think this really helps if he has that
other evidence if he has other evidence
of whether it's tax fraud or
um or kind of not claiming any of of the
tax related
tax-related perks that he was giving
these individuals i i do think but you
know you'd have to go into the grand
jury again you'd have to bring those
charges
and
against donald trump and you'd have to
present evidence you know and the way
you would do that is you would you would
look at tax both his tax returns
calamari's tax returns and you would see
um um the payroll taxes you know you
look at the various tax documents sorry
not probably not donald trump's tax
returns i i withdraw that you you would
look at calamari's tax returns um and
you would look at sort of the payroll
you know compensation and to see sort of
was any of this claimed um and you'd
yeah you know as as as income and if it
was not and you could prove that that it
was stuff that that trump you know paid
for that the organization paid for
um the fact that trump is now saying he
made those decisions i think that's
pretty good evidence and i i could see
it potentially
um
potential charges here but you know look
there's so many places i could see
potential charges
um you know whether it's in georgia you
know find more votes uh whether it's you
know the the the
real estate valuations you know alvin
bragg case whether it's this case i mean
there's so many things happening
um and you know one of them is going to
materialize at some point whether it's
whether it's um in state court whether
it's in federal court
um but the it seems like the the the
circle is is closing in a little bit you
know and this is this is yet another
pretty significant piece of evidence
that could be used directly against
donald trump himself not just the trump
organization so for these charges are
there any statute of limitations that go
with them absolutely
absolutely
and that's one of the one of the issues
is every every crime has a statute of
limitations except the most serious sort
of
uh rape or
murder those you know don't have
statutes of limitation in new york um
but any of these
white collar type crimes you know
whether it's tax fraud
um or
whatever else you could possibly um
bring against um against trump
you know they all have statutes of
limitations it depends on if they're
misdemeanors that have that have
lower statutes of limitation which are
usually around two years or felonies
which are usually around five years um
so it's it's you know and and trump's
tactic you know that's criminal statutes
of limitation of course civil
matters have have their own statutes of
limitation and and and it again depends
on the the um
the offense
but it's you know and that's part of
trump's tactic is litigate litigate
litigate litigate and therefore run out
the clock and try to run out the statute
and that was one of the issues uh that
um that was that that kerry done when he
argued before the supreme court of the
united states in and as well as in other
the federal courts all the way up to the
supreme court of the united states when
he was arguing about trying to get
trump's tax returns um one of the things
he kept we you know that he kept saying
was
was that the statute of limitations is
running on many of these and in fact ha
during the pendency of the investigation
actually some did run because trump used
this as an effective delay tactic
to
um not have the case be brought and now
they were barred but you know certain
charges were barred because of that the
delay tactic worked for him for two
reasons it worked for that and it also
worked because he waited out the old d.a
sci vance and got a new d.a
who you know sy vance again has been
widely reported was ready to go forward
and and alvin bragg took a look at it
and he had a different view
and that's always you know that's always
a risk that you get a new da and
um you know it happens a lot it happens
you know you you wait out the the person
whether it's the you know whether you
have a big civil case and you don't like
the mayor who you know who's who's the
mayor you have this big civil case
against the city and you don't like the
mayor you you try to delay things until
you get a new mayor who will hopefully
you know
who will hopefully have a sympathetic
ear to your position and and settle the
case in your favor you know it it just
you try to wait out your politicians and
in this particular case i i think it it
it worked in his in his favor so he he
successfully the one thing i will say he
successfully uses the the court system
you know he's a he's a prolific
litigator he's got you know more
lawsuits that he brings um or are
brought against him but you know he
again uses delay delay delay delay
that's a huge tactic he uses and
in this particular instance um
you know we'll see but this this is a
big deal this this development so
speaking of delays and delay delay delay
uh the delay at the new york attorney
general's uh content that contempt
charge that they have on him now that's
gonna cost him big time it's not just
gonna um and i mean ten thousand dollars
a day now to someone who thinks they're
as rich as donald trump maybe that's not
a lot but um it is gonna start to rack
up but it's gonna really start to apply
the pressure do you think that's gonna
be enough pressure um to get him to
actually go
testifying and why do you think he's
willing to spend ten thou ten thousand
dollars a day and i don't think money
means anything to him because he'll just
hold a rally and you know he'll
set up you know he'll have all his
his maga people who will happily pay
monthly recurring donations yeah i mean
look they they love the fact that he's
an obstructed obstructionist and and
won't you know won't listen to
um listen to authority i mean that's
partly i think that i think that's
what's part
they're the party of law and order yeah
just got to comply
it's like why wouldn't he just comply oh
right yeah
yeah the rules don't apply to him i
think i'll tell you what i think will i
think he will either
come up with the documents or he'll have
to put in an affidavit that he looked
and they don't exist
um which i think they do exist so i
don't know how he'll do that but um but
he he will comply he will get himself
out of civil contempt and the reason i
predict that he will is because uh there
are two types of contempt civil and
criminal and this is civil contempt
and the next step is criminal and i'll
explain what these are and why i think
the the
the prospect of being held in criminal
contempt actually will motivate him so
there's two types of of contempt um and
it's contempt of court it means you're
disobeying a court order and civil
contempt is uh is doesn't it it's
something that is designed to coerce you
or force you to do something so in this
case produce the documents and so most
normal people who are fined ten thousand
dollars a day would say okay that i
don't want to be fined ten thousand
dollars a day so i will go produce the
documents and and cure this and it and
it is coercive
um and and as soon as you you comply you
are no longer in contempt and so that's
what cures it
um however if he
continues to refuse to produce the
documents or produce an affidavit saying
i looked really hard and i couldn't find
my my post-it notes
with sharpie scribble on them um
if you know if he if he doesn't do that
he um
he can be held in what's called criminal
contempt that is going to get donald
trump's attention criminal contempt is
not designed to try to get you to do
something it's designed to punish and so
he and what they do is they put you in
jail and kind of like they did larry
flint back in the day when he wouldn't
produce his source for a tape yeah they
held him in criminal control can you
imagine donald trump at rikers island
that would be you know that's almost
worse i would love to imagine that i
would have loved it
i would go i would go visit him yeah so
that that's
that's that's what's looming over his
head if he if he ultimately doesn't uh
comply with the judge's order you know
the judge in this case you can tell was
very frustrated because
he's given him given trump multiple
opportunities to you know i need a
little more time okay i promise i will
get it to you okay you know this you
know kicking the can down the road delay
delay delay and the judge in this matter
ultimately you know
bangs down his gavel like you see on tv
and i read somewhere the judge was
interviewed saying he'd never used his
gavel before like i don't think i've
ever been in a courtroom with a judge
banging the gavel it's a dramatic
television every episode of svu right
well we were we were we were on live
last week in a great room
green and it was so boring and we were
commenting on how boring it was it would
be something to watch
that doesn't happen very often and
holding someone in contempt doesn't
happen very often i've personally seen
it very rarely
and you know i don't know anyone who
it's personally happened to it it's not
a thing that happens outside of
television to normal
law-abiding people you know trump isn't
if you had to kind of you know a uh
from your experience and kind of as you
assess the situation
how long
do we go from a civil contempt charge to
a criminal contempt charge like how long
like in the timeline we already have an
upset frustrated judge who's like [ __ ]
this i already had to hit my gavel this
is crazy
uh just do what i ask
and then we get to a point where trump
does take it seriously he will take it
seriously because it's criminal so like
how long do you think between you know
uh earlier this week or late last week
to
the point at which he says okay this is
now criminal so i think i think what's
going to happen is the lawyer is going
to alina the haba or whatever is his
latest kind of
um
lawyer you know you don't really see
giuliani anymore ever since he um and
these are these are all lawyers from the
same law firm or is he just like picking
and choosing random people
i don't even know who honestly i have
never heard of this person i don't know
um
um he who knows p who i know so many
people because you know who who trump
has reached out
to uh represent him and
i don't know anyone who would touch him
with a 20-foot pole who's a real um
lawyer they want money they you know how
about the money yeah it's not about the
money he's just you know first of all i
think he
um the thing that the tactics he would
like people to employ
any ethical lawyer uh
wouldn't do wouldn't bring the frivolous
lawsuits that he asks them to bring
wouldn't bring the frivolous motions
that he asked them to do i mean any
serious lawyer um wouldn't do most of
the things that that donald trump has
asked his lawyers to do
i also just think donald trump is i
think a lot of people think it's immoral
you know to represent someone like him
yeah and so you know but so this
particular lawyer um
alina haba
um i think my guess is she'll she'll um
sign she'll produce a few things you
know like they'll say oh you know we
looked in this particular file cabinet
and we found you know a few things so i
think she'll she'll try to be cute in
that way and i think she'll also then
file a sworn affidavit from her saying
that they've looked in all the other
places that and she'll have to say you
know where she looked uh when she looked
what she looked for you know she'll have
to be very specific um
and
we'll see if the judge finds that
sufficient i think the judge might
actually require donald trump to swear
under oath in an affidavit that he
looked and that this is all there is or
that these things don't exist um and
we'll see if the judge you know finds
their what i predict to be
you know half-baked
um
response you know
whether the judge finds that to be
responsive
but if there is no response then he
could hold him in in criminal contempt
or if they continue to sort of
not respond meaningfully but you know
timing wise it's hard to say i it's
again such an extraordinary thing it's
it i think the judge would give him
multiple times multiple opportunities um
on top of the multiple opportunities
he's already had yeah yeah
well you know speaking of time we're
running out of it but karen i so
appreciate you coming giving us the
analysis so i'll admit to the audience i
was getting a lot wrong about the
deposition i'm glad you came in i hope i
didn't get anything wrong because like i
i just saw it today so if i got
something wrong i apologize we'll try to
we'll try to fix it if you did i'm sure
i'm sure you i won't apologize for
anything i said no right i'm not i'm not
held accountable for anything i'll take
the drum stand you will not have any way
i can make a little plug yeah go ahead
go ahead yes it's denim day today which
is why i'm wearing denim
i don't know if you know what
international denim day is but it's
sexual assault awareness month and and
denim day is a big sexual assault day
uh that a lot of people in solidarity
solidarity around the world wear denim
to bring
um to bring awareness to the issue of
sexual assault because uh it arises from
italy i think 23 24 years ago
there was a case in italy where a woman
accused a man of rape he was convicted
of rape and
the case was appealed and the judges the
three judges on appeal
ruled that uh dismis reversed the
conviction and said she wasn't raped
because she was wearing tight jeans and
therefore to get the tight jeans off she
must have
in some way acquiesced and helped him
uh to get her pants off thereby
consenting to the sexual assault and the
next day the italian
members of par the women in the italian
parliament came to work all wearing
denim in solidarity uh with the sexual
assault survivor and since then every
year
on this day um it's denim day and people
wear denim all over the world in
solidarity of sexual assault survivors
so well that's all that's interesting
i'm gonna run and put a pair of blue
jeans on because i think that's a good
idea even though after the pandemic i
hate blue i like i i personally weighs
down tony is just in
me wearing blue jeans you see me wearing
a jeans that's right well that's true i
don't have a dinner i don't have a
dinner
the
is blue jeans so i'll make sure to wear
a pair of blue jeans today also i want
you to plug your show because it comes
out
tonight correct tonight tonight at eight
eastern legal af uh with me and michael
popock and we discussed denim day and we
discuss um
we discuss a few other things as well
it'll be a fun
it'll be it'll be a fun conversation so
join us live uh live chatting
awesome so just go to the minus touch
youtube page and then you can download
it you can download it anywhere you get
your podcast so go over to my touch
youtube page and watch legal af tonight
what time uh eastern does it start karen
do you know eight o'clock eastern the
midas touch youtube channel go watch
karen and michael popock break down the
legal issues of the day and talk about
denim day thank you karen for joining us
thank you for bringing that down uh
don't don't go anywhere everybody uh
we're gonna be right back now we're
gonna take a quick break we'll be right
back after these messages thank you
karen
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker convoy
there's tammy by the time we reached dc
we was 50 strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way
we got plenty of slim jims
skull
near run out natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
circle the city again
here's
bob
dear bob
i'm fixing to send you some more of them
doritos you like the red bag not the lib
loving blue one
in your absence i discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
ears
tammy
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
[Music]
aaron at kippelope from legally kfa
this is her breakdown of the trump
deposition i got it all wrong
i'll admit i'll admit classic tony when
you said it i was like i feel i was like
i thought i read something different but
i was like maybe there was an update in
the article it happens it happens it
happens when i'm wrong i'm not wrong
about elon musk though i know and i i am
going to stick to my guns on this he
listen when i say this you can play this
tape back and say you're wrong dumbass
he is not going to own twitter he owns a
bit of twitter here we go april 27 2022
tony says
elon will not end up owning twitter
right here live now
i think that's a total possibility i'm
still 50 50 on it i still think there is
that i still think that he has to
there's a possibility he battens down
the hatches and he does commit because
again
there's a whole his elon musk he's got
his board on tesla there's a one billion
dollar termination fee well it's like ah
you know so there's there's a few things
that are at play where i'm like
let's get him on the show i'll talk to
him yeah get him over here
you know a couple of my tweets i was
hoping that either i would get blocked
or get a response from him nothing yet i
i would i would get elon on the show and
you know i would not be cordial at all
but i and i would probably eat his lunch
he's a weirdo in interviews but come on
the show elon and we'll talk to you
we'll send him five bucks for a new
haircut
get it get him a decent [ __ ] haircut
yeah okay it's speaking speaking of um
speaking of weirdos and interviews uh
have you seen this video by the good
liars this one here it's so hard to keep
up i feel like this one this one's a gem
as you see here uh this guy here i told
you earlier this has got jfk enter
junior enters the chat if you look here
he's wearing a shirt that says trump
plus jfk junior 2021
so his shirt that he's wearing to this
rally is already outdated um these
people i don't get it 2021 like do they
think that there was a special election
that was going to happen i don't know
where jfk junior all of a sudden went
and became a conservative like these are
all good questions these are all really
really good hard-hitting questions these
are the questions i try to avoid but
somehow you make me ask them tony right
exactly well this is how it works and it
looks like a husband and wife bear here
i'm not really sure of their relation
please don't procreate well yeah but
they're asking
they're asking
you mean jfk junior and this guy or
these the husband oh just these two like
you know i'm just well i'm just you know
couple brain cells rubbing together here
right but this appears to be um
outside the gated parking area as we
know they gain in the parking areas now
they lock you in you can't leave leave
the rallies we've heard that from the
fence and that's got barbed wire over
there yeah it looks like a prison almost
like a trump prison but listen listen to
the dialogue and listen
well listen to the theories because
you've seen the video where the person
thought that princess diana was still
alive right you've seen that one yep
yeah yeah yeah okay now listen to what
this that was on and that was on the uh
that was on a news station right for
uh right or rsbn or whatever right they
were airing it as if it was news yeah
they're like hey this is good listen to
what this lady says about
joe biden and jim carrey i think she's
watching too many movies and getting
movies confusion
listen here listen you think biden is
not alive right now no the guy that's
doing the stand-up job of trying to wake
people up is an actor wearing a mask i
mean he's an actor wearing a mask okay
so he's got a mask on jim carrey did
play biden on snl right and he did do a
movie called the mask the mask but
listen in listen in several different
people playing joe biden at this point
and when when he fell up the stairs
going on the airplane
so you remember the video yeah yeah yeah
i remember wind was blowing he kind of
stumbles a bit he struggles to get you
know
joe biden isn't is an old guy but he
doesn't struggle to go down a ramp or
really up and running he doesn't go
sometimes you trip on the stairs right i
mean this is a presidential moment that
happens a lot i mean you can drink with
water with one hand
right right he can use right only one
hand i have a good story after the show
for you gabe that we might we might do
something with this about uh and well
we'll have to do that but i don't want
to give it away on air but anyways
the moment a lot of people don't
understand like an airport there's a lot
of wind right and and they always have
open steps to get an air force one
they're not hooked to the terminal or
anything right and and there's a lot of
wind so a lot of times when you're
coming down or going upstairs there's a
lot of wind so if you stumble but here's
the thing
is listen to who she thinks actually
stumbled it was joe biden i'll admit
that but listen who she thinks it was
they swapped i myself think that that
was jim carrey i've heard that he was
one of them
[Laughter]
good night goodbye i'm done this this
lady
this lady thinks that jim carrey is the
one
who who fell down the steps
um or fell up the step well whatever
again she's getting she's getting a
couple things confused here listen to
the question he asked hey
wait wait you think that
jim carrey was wearing a mask
and
was the acting president and being silly
by falling up the stairs three different
times she literally she's watching
footage of the president united states
she's watching snl as you alluded to
that jim carrey plays joe biden on snl
and then she's watching the movie the
mask i think
and she's really kind of getting these
things they watch way too many [ __ ]
movies man these crazy wackadoo q anon
folks watch way
too much tv they watch way too many
movies it is absolutely insane it gets
it gets better gabe it gets better
it gets so much better here
and james woods also i think is one of
them
james woods is a is a biden actor oh
that's what she's saying that's what
she's saying that's what she's saying
here at the end listen uh let me pull it
back let me pull it back here listen
and james woods also i think is one of
the
doppelganger mask wearing
people
so here's the thing here's the thing
james woods and jim carrey are
doppelgangers with mask on which is not
doppelgangers are not
they don't i i don't know she know what
doppelganger means but
james woods is a conservative he is
right trump
humping concern
but gabe who better to play joe biden
than someone who would implement the
policies that you'd want to implement so
when gas when gas prices go up wait no
no no no no no that was that oh no that
was yeah that was
that was jim carrey doing that that was
jim carrey playing joe biden got it got
it okay oh my [ __ ] god this is
this is what we have to contend with and
and really honestly i i said this uh
before you came in the air
these people are getting dumber and
dumber and dumber at his rallies and
it's not surprising that the the dumb is
staying with him and the people who
aren't completely [ __ ] delusional and
lost their minds and just off their
rockers are starting to peel away from
him that's why i believe we're seeing
dumber and dumber at his rallies
not to be confused with the jim carrey
movie dumb and dumber but it is it is
starting to leak into fantasy right
i
yeah i just i knew it would leave you
speechless i don't even know what like i
you you you listen to that and you go
what
right like there's no there's no other
way to be like oh like is she is she
punking like the big the the good liars
like is that what she's doing you know
and it's like no this is actually
someone who legitimately 100 percent
lives in a reality where she believes
biden isn't really biden or has actors
who are playing biden which is a
comedian known as jim carrey and a
right-wing nut job former actor uh
uh straight to dvd james woods
who you know it's like it doesn't make
any sense
well is it supposed to that's the thing
here again i've said this over and over
again we are at the intersection of
wrestlemania and real life and on one s
on one corner there's the facebook
ivermectin group and the on the other
corner is the q anon headquarters i just
feel like soon it's just becoming 100
wrestlemania like that's what like there
is no really yeah
reality is leaving the right one-way
street and there is no intersection it's
just uh it's just uh it's straight
somebody at one point was like hey maybe
this is a two-way and they're like no
it's a one-way one-way dirt road q anon
avenue it really it really is it really
is it really is beautiful that the more
the the more trouble donald trump gets
in the more people are peeling away the
crazier his rallies become
guys honestly in a couple months after
they have chosen a bunch of trump
trumpers to be their candidates and they
hold these rallies and they're inviting
these people to these rallies to try to
prop up their candidacy for the 2022
midterm election they are going to give
us everything we need to prop up our
messaging to beat back this trumpism and
to win the 2022 midterms they are
terrified of it just listen to the tapes
that kevin mccarthy released from him
being terrified of what these morons are
saying and this ass this tape has to
terrify them even more and i am super
glad that people keep putting
microphones in front of these people's
places place
in front of these people's faces see i'm
are you an actor is someone i am going
to be tony i i this is jim carrey with a
tony mask on oh i'm a big fan right and
i know i know
speaking of microphones in front of
faces don't miss tomorrow the show noon
eastern 11 central 9 pacific we will be
in front of microphones tomorrow every
single weekday on youtube twitter twitch
and now from the minus touch facebook
page don't forget to subscribe follow
and do the likes and the comments and
whatever you're supposed to do right
all that good stuff all that good stuff
and until tomorrow noon eastern 11
central nine pacific surfs up
[ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking